[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en fait c'est là où je me dis que
j'aurais peut-être pas dû remplacer
cyril parce que ça à mon avis c'est pour
se [ __ ] sur la figure alors le
principe est simple c'est que la météo
c'est quoi c'est de la neige et du vent
et de la pluie c'est voilà donc en fait
je vais poser une question c'est la zone
et surtout c'est la journée mondiale de
la météo sera absolument mexique il a
bossé
non non non non on veut venir à son
secours
donc en fait je lance une question si
vous mettez bien 10 secondes à répondre
ok je mettrai des choses sur la figure
dans l'accord attends tu mettais à kiel
et sur la figure alors normalement c'est
sur la mienne est comme suit le chef
première question c'est parti quel
organisme a demandé aux chaînes de
télévision d'utiliser moins de mots
provenant de l'anglais moi on m'a dit
c'est sa bonne réponse qu'elle n'a rien
compris mamie donc en fait c'est si vous
répondez en moins de 10 secondes mais
j'ai mis moins de 10 secondes
[Rires]
attendez je regarde quelle est la
sanction ça va c'est des feuilles
jusque-là ça alors l'ajout des rares
qui va remplacer sandrine quétier à la
place attendait miss univers iris mais
tonnerre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà là je me sens bien la patte de
série voilà d'un coup 21% les jeunes
pensent que le sida peut être transmis
d'une certaine manière laquelle le
divine la transpiration des cieux pseudo
bon de vous voir pour houllier voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quel politicien apparaît dans une vidéo
où il fait péter une charge par le livre
oui gardez vos réponses par dont on rêve
ou le vp choix et vers des sommets
marchand melançon bonnes réponses sur
safin et c'est toi non
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi c'est quand même beaucoup
plus colorée voilà